I can't I can't look at it greetings to
podcast Ville this episode of the church
what's happened now is brought to you by
Anka if you ever wanted to make a
podcast like this one but thought the
process will be expensive and horrible
no need to worry
anchor is the quickest and easiest way
to make and distribute your own podcasts
just don't just download the app record
with your phone and bat publish bets of
all it's completely free on the arm so
check it out and make your own podcast
at anchor dot F M slash Church that's
anchor dot F M slash Church this podcast
is also brought to you by my favorite
product in the whole [ __ ] world
toshiba day AKA hello to chicom listen
it's that time of year when you look at
your relatives you know like I wonder
what my grandmother's [ __ ] smells
like while she's making pasta or [ __ ]
lasagna you got and she's eating [ __ ]
the whole morning in front of you and
you're like I wonder what my
grandmother's [ __ ] must smell like
listen you don't have to want to know
more because the hell does she you know
it smells [ __ ] good
hello oh she has a portable bidet you
would store right in your own [ __ ]
bathroom do you understand me
no more stories no more nothing you
could defeat that hemorrhoid juice could
kill that [ __ ] those barnacles have
your wife shave your [ __ ] like I did
and then hit it with that [ __ ] water
every day and ya [ __ ] will be tip-top
Magoo in the winter you rub a little
[ __ ] hand cream on the [ __ ] and
it's [ __ ] perfect although you
understand me
how old do she also makes towels and
also they come in different colors but
listen seriously how finally more
[ __ ] years gonna give somebody a time
or wallet or something they ain't gonna
do dick you want to give something a
gift cuz you want to change their life
right a roll
get me a [ __ ] bottle birthday and
make sure their [ __ ] is tip-top Magoo
year-round with a good [ __ ] attitude
go - hello - she calm and use code
church and get 10% off your order again
go hello - she Dom and use the code
Church
for 10% off your order kick this [ __ ]
melee yeah it's a beautiful day to be
alive what's going on you bad
[ __ ]
it's Monday [ __ ] and you made it
who's better than you
AJ Benza Wow Lisa at we had a great
weekend everything was happy I want to
thanks Takens for sending us those dirty
[ __ ] boxes stinkums I haven't had
them yet oh but I'm ready for my [ __ ]
to explode for that [ __ ] bidet let me
say something about stinking likely came
back and he said he's [ __ ] right away
you know why there's a new interstate if
it replenishes your system in shock
it's like [ __ ] drinking water on the
Hudson [ __ ] River you know be sick
for an hour - but let me tell you some
your immune system you could flunk a
crack hole while they're shooting you
and [ __ ] and with the flu bug while
they're shootin [ __ ] the bowl up your
[ __ ] and your coffee
you'll [ __ ] be and you'll be right
back at work tomorrow in the morning you
have this lace-up combo packs that's
yours
that'll be a great combo pack what's
that steak comes in the Toshiba day
together by OMA and by the way I was
thinking about it if you have like a
white elephant like a Secret Santa
that's a perfect gift for that I was
that what that would be they come to the
office steak comes but I was talking
about Toshi my steak comes with onion
you you you [ __ ] do them up with
onions nice a little garlic in the pan
forget about [ __ ] roll provolone get
about it with some more rider fresh [ __ ]
I would stand up at this sink and not
even sit down and eat them just let the
[ __ ] juice really say oh my god I was
telling these guys I I had him they used
to kill my mother
yeah and I'm a little cooler at Cuban
meal right I won't you don't want to eat
[ __ ] steak that must have killed
killed hungry never liked that [ __ ]
course and I went on those for like a
year straight every night so I took ash
every night every [ __ ] night while I
showered the French fries would be
getting cooked oh my god I come down
with underwear and cook the steak oven
underwear and sneakers on like a savage
on the Sam sacrilegious day that I would
eat and pick the fob would even put the
fries in the dish
Oh
run after Ted from the oven he just put
salt out of a pepper little cool down by
the time they're cooling down the steak
him is cooking you blast it out and you
need to stay comes yeah you know me you
know me dog and Cuban you give me white
Wonder Bread
one day my fresh Wonder bread a little
bit of toast on a little bit of money
but to stay come on there well long buzz
my warm warm butter with the [ __ ] now
with with the cheese yeah brand new oh
she's on anything you're fine your brand
[ __ ] then we can't I was telling them
I ate them for so long when I play
basketball with ah that was the week I
was clogged up like it was like I ate 50
like it is yeah yeah with you five
minutes had been up I went up my fingers
and tried to get it out my god when
you're sitting in the car you're in
[ __ ] pain and that's why I had those
farts not that pre fart before we think
yeah the cork and let me tell you some
that whole bus was bluffing and then I
farted again a while away they kept
saying he's changing flavors was [ __ ]
crazy was the chili loser crying there
was a bunch of chew it is like white
jigs that would make some variety
Italian because their father died all
that [ __ ] life my father used to
fought in the frozen food section we
were sharpening he'd hang is there so
would like to meet the frozen foot and
he fought and he block us in I was
murder baby laughs he loved it I love it
I love it when you fart nobody knows at
the time he fought it so bad at work
that the person that weren't called to
fight upon so it was a gas screech that
he knew was his father you laugh you're
an [ __ ] the best story of my entire
family was my dad farted it made my
cousin throw up I was like 10 it was a
girl and she came running she ran into
the room we're playing video games she's
like your dad farted threw up in the
bathroom
it was the best day of my life so what
the [ __ ] have you been since I last saw
you
well if I've been I've been you know I
took a question I haven't seen you I'm
gonna be honest it's gotta be ten years
and use just finishing up at A&E maybe
what was the challenge there was a real
job I stopped with E in 2000 so you know
what I did a I did mysteries and
scandals at Eve for five six years then
I did
high stakes poker on game show network
which was a really good show for poker
fans for five years everybody watched it
I was I was with Gabe Gabe Kaplan was my
cause
I was his tallest because he knows poker
and that was a show that just took off
we had billboards in Vegas million
dollar buying games was hot [ __ ]
when poker was at its zenith you know
and that was great and then the economy
you know 2006 whatever that year was
when the whole everything [ __ ] fell
out and I fell out everything fell out
there they did that the network dropped
the show and then it was an odyssey then
I just didn't know what to do and I
ended up go I had a book I had an idea
for a book and I went to New York to
live with my sister all right my sister
bought the house we lived in his kids so
I went back with my wife and my kids to
go to New York cause I was writing a
book about the summer of 1974 about
there was a summer where my father was a
tough Sicilian his brother was a doctor
but he had a gay son from New Jersey and
then his second son who was 10 was
showing the same signs of being gay also
so my father's brother called one night
in the summer of 74 it was so vivid I
wrote a book about it and I heard my
uncle talking on the phone saying to my
father out you know Gino is showing the
same signs as Larry he's shown he has
brain damage they called the brain
damage in the 70s not not he's gay
homosexual brain damage and my uncle
begged my father can you take Gino for
the summer you know your house is loud
you got the music you got those yet the
homemade wine you play stickball Playboy
magazines everywhere AJ just but toughen
him up let's get him out of it and my
father said sure we'll take him in so
for that summer we took in my my
effeminate cousin and we thought we'll
change him we didn't know what the [ __ ]
we were doing but what happened
inevitably was that he changed us my
father saw that okay this isn't gonna be
what I thought it was he's gay and we
got to adapt to him we got to protect
them and nurture him and make him
stronger
and it was a wonderful summer and I
wrote a book called 74 and sunny that
came out in 2015 and it was a beautiful
summer and obviously my cousin grew up
to be gay he's married now living in New
York but that's somewhat changed my life
but it was a it was an amazing time
because my father who look my father was
the Sicilian Archie Bunker
I heard [ __ ] [ __ ] I heard [ __ ] I mean
he didn't give a [ __ ] he was against all
flags but when he saw my cousin that was
obviously gay he said okay I get a check
so one day this is when everything
changed this is a scene out of a [ __ ]
movie and it will be I'm in the pool my
father goes grab the pole I gotta talk
this was mad he goes come here catapult
and we go to the front of the house and
we lived on Long Island nice
neighborhood and on the sidewalk in
front of the house it said in in chalk
go home queer so some but some kids
wanted it they were sending a message to
my cousin my father who did this I said
I don't know I said it might be the
Dugan brothers there were three Irish
kids down his face and I saw them
earlier we're gonna take a walk so my
father who was an X undercover cop he
puts a [ __ ] gun in his back waistband
of his dungarees shorts and he's holding
me my hand I'm 12 my cousin hit my
cousin's 10 and we start walking to this
house to the Irish House and my for my
father says point watch house I said
they live over there dad he knocks on
the door mr. Dougan is a banker he comes
down how can I help you yeah mr. Dougan
I'm al Benza uh hi what's the problem
well I think your son's wrote something
on my sidewalk that's not too nice well
I don't think my sons would do that well
they wrote home or go home queer they
wrote well listen mr. Benson maybe you
ought to take this someplace else
because obviously you know you're wrong
my father punched through the screen
door knocked the guy down open the door
just sat on top of them put the gun to
his head and said I'll [ __ ] blow your
heads I'll blow your brains out in front
of your kids get your sons down here now
to clean my [ __ ] sidewalk and the guy
called his sons down did you do this and
I said yeah we did they clean the
sidewalk and my father's watching and as
they're cleaning he's going you you want
to go in the pool you want some
hamburgers I'll put something on the
grill no no we're okay but I ended up
being best friends with Danny Dugan for
the next ten years it was a my father
was a lot like DeNiro in and in many of
his movies just tough didn't give a [ __ ]
and he I took a lot of scenes from that
summer and wrote a book booked it well
great reviews and it got option and now
we're close to getting a development
deal to to write the screenplay and make
it into a film so the point is I was in
Long Island to live with my sister to
write the book but for a year I couldn't
get a deal so I lived in New York and I
had no [ __ ] money this is six years
ago and I ended up driving a cab 12 14
hours a day on Long Island and then I
did another job I worked at Best Buy
selling TVs now get this Joey I'm at
Best Buy selling TVs with the [ __ ]
blue shirt everybody's 22 years old I'm
49 and you know they they they have
things they have their movies on every
TV era as I'm selling TVs they got Rocky
Balboa playing cuz Rocky was had just
come out on DVD so the movie I'm in is
playing and people are seeing me in a
movie
what's the loan and I'm selling them a
[ __ ] 55 inch TV how did that feel it
was initially horrifying and then I got
a kick out of it and I had fun with it
and I started putting those DVDs in
every TV in the store and matter of fact
I found other films I was in and put
those movies in the screen and the
management said I come on knock it off
now it was very humbling but it was it
was something I had to go through and
the book sold
I got a nice advance with that advance I
came back to LA and I was able to stop
my life again with my wife and kids and
and and I thought I started producing a
movie which was a great 4-year job
produced a movie called so be it it's
out in theaters now it's a children's
book we turned into a film
so everything happens for a reason I'm
alive yeah well I was driving a cab I
was driving a cab around the
neighborhood I grew up in but I was I
was writing down scenes in the book I
don't know what it all had to happen as
horrifying as it felt to work 1214 hours
and come home with $40 it had to happen
and it worked out for the better just
going back home yeah to that house and
I'm the guy who left Long Island I left
my left my little town the guy that made
it I'm the guy that olj Benza in my high
school there's nobody else in my high
school that I mean plenty of guys my
high school are successful in different
fields but no one went to showbiz so
when they saw me it was you know I know
some people saw me and they didn't want
me to see that they saw me and that that
looked like I don't want to I don't want
it to no we saw because this is a this
is really hurtful that he's here but I
did it you know and I'd steal I'd steal
toys for my little son I'd steal a
little these things called sky land
these these little toys that were really
expensive that best boy
all right stuff in my socks cuz I
couldn't afford to buy him I'm glad it
happened but the the horrifying thing
was I'm sleeping in the same bed I slept
in as a kid now with my son who's two in
a single bed my wife and my daughter are
sleeping in another bedroom in a single
bed talked about that was insane to be
back in your [ __ ] bed from childhood
after having been in movies and TV shows
and you name it that was really
something else I'm glad it happened no
and it brought you back yeah you're back
from the right to go back see I tell
people if you ever confused
you'd having a hard time it's just a
feeling you get well you know you can't
move forward that means you gotta go
back to basics
yeah this happened to me in 93 hmm and
there's broke as I was I'm right for
Nagle to buy a plane ticket back to
Jersey and I bumped I told the guy in
front of me a thousand ten milligram
valiums
we'll see him in two days that's when I
called my buddies jerseys
coming with valium right at least I had
a couple thousand right off the bat
right and he started right and when I
came back to you and I gave the guy the
money what happened I lost your phone
number ah man that that was [ __ ] up
you you were great guy I was gonna send
people to go looking for him and wash
your phone number I walked around the
street to where I grew up I would like
forced myself to walk I did to walk take
them there was no ferry in those days I
took the bus right to Port Authority and
I and there was days I I worked with a
car dealership as a salesman on 57th and
12th Avenue Ola by DiMasi Cadillac and
all the car dealership and I would go
over there with just enough money to eat
yeah I would have to be in a ten and I'd
have to take the seven o'clock bus yeah
as my friend's dad drove the bus and I
would get on though this is at the be
doing time yeah coming out doing
something with my life and then that
getting divorce it took me all the way
down to square root but walking in those
streets nine months yeah
even though I was doing ball nine days a
week right he no matter what I was doing
I was toughening up and I went to
Colorado and Here I am it was because
that little nine months that really put
everything into it I went into a club I
saw like his arm Oh on stage and put the
process together I had already started
stand-up but I really didn't know what I
was doing I was walking around waiting
for Johnny Carson the same things you
know that's the mistake we make for the
real he was seeing yeah and nobody would
see me like I gotta put work into this
all right now I get it but there's
something interesting that came up
you're 55 yeah was your birthday June
2nd oh so you just turned 55 well he's
five in February twenty eighth nineteen
okay and it's real interesting because I
want most for people that listen to this
show demographic is not our age they
younger they're very young yeah you know
Lee's 29 you know 29 my mom my life
didn't start at 30 when we watch TV we
watch old films and they don't have cell
phones I know and we're talking about in
front of Lee or whatever you know
explain to these people because people
have no [ __ ] idea
I told the story on Comedy Central I had
a bunch of rude or for joke I told on
this thing about a guy that I grew up
with that was more in the fact in
Spanish he was mud thing of money :
maricon sure everybody know who he was
he was a health not God I see no have
seen a for a big plane right right and
this has got to be 74 yeah yeah 74
seconds I'm I was 73 10 mm-hmm I went to
see the Mets play the [ __ ] guys I met
the best play the Reds in the World
Series with people he throws eggs I'm
beat up by the handles in my house and
it was about 2 years after that that he
pulled the gun at my mother's bowhunting
of money gone really because somebody
called him a ding and mati called out to
his face it was well known he was gay
but just don't break his balls the fan
and every night he come he would his
whole thing was he was a seamstress then
he'd take the muscle to Jersey take a
shower get an ounce of blowing 20s and
take it to CBGB's and ah well let me
tell you some I'd see him once a week
and he always had a black eye a tooth
missing got to ship it out every night
it was some drama and I said on stage on
that you know you should thank [ __ ]
like Martin because he was one of the
originals he took the beatings for you
more so a great line it's very hard to
explain to somebody like Lee how hard it
was to be gay in 1970 mmunity ok but you
didn't accept it there was a ton you
couldn't have long hair neighborhood
when he came hoarse 9y came from well
that was my first move from New York
City
yeah for maybe a few till of Bergen that
was 1210 it was no longer I had long
hand it was all right there was her off
and I had thought and I was I'm Sicilian
so I had dark skin I was called [ __ ] a
lot a lot I had fights because I was
going there I know that's what isn't a
looks thing but a few weeks ago Joe was
telling a story about someone was
cross-country skiing in their
neighborhood and that just wasn't and
some guys were sitting there the time
first of all the mindset was this that
snowed its 1983 it snowed goofy the snow
in those days it crippled the city
we couldn't gamble because there was no
Daily News right the book only had
action on two teams Brown in st. Lucia
some [ __ ] martyr and the coke guy was
out of service yeah cuz he couldn't get
out of his car worse so for three days
we'll scratch him like monkeys right had
my friends in front of a bar window
waiting right for heaven to drive around
skies yeah he's got like a mug of beer
ESPN on he's losing and I'm sitting next
to him he's by the bar window and he's
looking at and there's not a car on the
street the streets of ice everything is
part some cars haven't been moved three
feet of snow and um right and we're
sitting there he's with a half a mood
listen he looks at and this is [ __ ]
soon we cross Carlos cuz in 1983
Oliver's friend looks Vegas what the
[ __ ] I'll do it now then I guess what is
that and he jumped out of his shell he
chased him I'm just gonna beat the [ __ ]
out then we all kicked him one time
right we go back in we had a janitor in
those days from the high school that we
were drunk they were all drunk when he
gets right he was epileptic yeah so he
would have we'd steal the epileptic no
nice split him in half and we got [ __ ]
up anything that will [ __ ] up to the
gills yes in the morning I'm seeing
police lights on the wall and I go on
the dude we beat up is the back of the
cop with a blanket on Shaymin right I
know I know it's it was it was so tough
you know to be gay like it was so tough
I was dying I look I didn't know what it
was so it didn't bother yeah I just
heard okay so so we when you guys were
10 or 11 13 whatever the age was what
did he think of gay people
honest to god yeah I didn't think about
them at all
my I grew up inside my house was my
mother my aunt lived with us my mother
might might not the other aunt was two
doors down and her daughter my two
sisters lived with us I grew up with all
women so I only heard my father came
home with 10 p.m. ate dinner had two
scotches I went to bed I heard female
stories all day but there was no gate
there were no
gays stories there was nothing like that
to kick around but when my cousin showed
up you know my father it was a phrase my
father would say when my uncle called
and said I think Gino is a brain damaged
it was a very quiet night it was like 1
o'clock in the morning and I'm looking
at my bedroom door and I saw my father
go to my mother Larry thinks Gino's uh
Familia and he grabbed his ear he shook
his ear and I don't know what that was a
thing they did back then and I don't
know what it meant why you'd grab the
knee when someone was gay and I would I
would I deduced is I guess gays wore
earrings back then guys you know things
were earrings you couldn't wear any
right label no so I think that's why did
he hear and I tell you when when when
they when my uncle came with this song
with his son and we went on the ball we
want fish in the ladies were so
concerned like how's everything what
happened you know is everything yeah and
and my father was like it hurt him it
hurt him that his brother's son was gay
and he said my mother said well look you
know it's not the worst things in the
world my father at Memory said it's
[ __ ] close that's close he got mad
like you know I'm a man that's not
something a father wants to go through
so this is many many years ago now if my
son was gay I would buy him the best
makeup I would make sure he had the best
[ __ ] clothes it wouldn't bother me
iiiiii it really wouldn't bother me I
swear to God my son's an athlete he's a
great athlete
I wouldn't bust his balls I wouldn't go
to bed at night and wring my hands as I
got older in life I just want my kids to
be happy now being happy and being gay
it nowadays is easily achievable but in
the 70s it was [ __ ] impossible she's
gonna get [ __ ] killed when I moved to
Jersey the toughest family in the
neighborhood had a kid that was
effeminate and at that time I know but
let me tell you a funny story
we called him feel yeah we've been to
Cuba couple three times I love Cuba has
a very huge gay Society oh very big
prostitution Simon huh I know I enjoyed
it Rick
Haven of death but they also decided to
have is his Olympics talked about before
Islam across society I'm a quad its
Santeria I did I went and log on I could
see the bracelets me and he was crazy
there's a thing that Taba Quan they were
the Longshoremen's of Cuba really and
they were the men of Cuba they were the
Sicilians of Cuba
they were so Sicilian they couldn't eat
[ __ ] oh I think you're right about they
couldn't be in another room they
couldn't be in a room if Lea was gay I
have to walk on the right nothing
against Lee then I gonna say nothing no
but they don't want to be around oh they
don't want to be around it because of my
Santeria roots there's a lot of gay guys
in the Santeria room and there was one
in particular that was about eight okay
and he was partners of my mother is some
venture change around good guy
nice to remember but whatever he would
see me he was scammed yeah and he'll
always he wouldn't say sexual things to
me cuz my mom was in the room he would
always say to walk go ahead and in some
Spanish national and some Spanish
circles that means I'm gonna [ __ ] you
what they wanted one was ah but Juan
didn't play that [ __ ] at all if we came
time to hug him you put his hand out and
shake their hand and it was embarrassing
I want acted but he never lashed out in
fact he always spoke to my mother's bar
he was friends of Martin when he heard
that that guys say that to me pulled me
aside one day and he goes don't ever let
that [ __ ] say that day yeah
[ __ ] says that T again patty nanaka
Miley kick him in the [ __ ] balls
right on mass shoot him I mean it was it
was scared mind that the situation came
up and he said it and I went off on him
in front of my mother my mother got
pissed and but uh nice it was such a
touchy
it's very situation in those days and I
see it men
now today I'm gay friend nothing that I
don't care I don't care at all that
there's not but I'll tell you my
brother-in-law is 70 years 71 years old
he's been with me since I'm five years
old so he's like my father and Spanish
Puerto Rican tough queens guy you know
and when his little son
Jackie was growing up you know we were
watching the cabaret and my sister put
him she put a little Rouge on his cheek
she put him in Louisville she put him in
a little black dress it was funny we
just were laughing around the house my
father dressed as Joel Grey from cabaret
and she made her son to look like like
kind of like Liza Minnelli he was like
two is three
well the foot might my brother my saw it
you wouldn't you would have thought he
saw him sucking [ __ ] that's how [ __ ]
manicott
you know Spanish Italian to let the
Latin people they don't they he get that
[ __ ] dress off my son his face got
red yeah I'll tell you what the worst
and I'm if I ever get to meet him I'm
gonna pull him aside and asked him why
he put that in his pilot oh and then it
was brilliant
the pilot the Empire yeah sorry okay the
pilot to help I there's a scene in the
beginning when the kid comes down with a
dress I know and shoes on I remember the
[ __ ] put on ballistic and he picks
him up and puts me in a garbage can and
he puts a little over it so genius scene
let me tell you something guys my first
friend when I came from Cuba mo had a
ball other 27th and West End there
whenever that Street is right off but I
saw ya right up on the Upper West Side
is a black ball right love this my
mother's partnership was the black dude
but I would go in there and I became
friends and I became friends old black
and the kid was my Goomba ran around and
went all the way ball chains bridle
records rags I love it it took me to the
project so I ain't with his family he's
great there was some times my mom let me
sleep over and Saturdays and they picked
me up on Sundays and I stir them with
1968 like there was yesterday
the father in that house going off about
the brother-in-law was gay well you know
when I'm in this [ __ ] [ __ ]
shadow want no [ __ ] in my
mother father I know he would say [ __ ]
now I was five and I was scared yeah
yeah yeah and I would go home and ask my
mom mom
but didn't really know the juban about
she didn't know the American
translations yeah so go to bed but he
was all about their brother-in-law being
gay like the wife's brother mm-hmm and
I'm gonna figure we'll have a Saturday
night right and he embarrassed the guy
in front of us and then he told the wife
one time when I was there eating I don't
want a mini what I mean if there's gonna
rule my [ __ ] that night no [ __ ]
like that
I'm having a beef I still remember being
five in know Wow
yeah his hatred for that man and finally
years later I figure out why the guy was
[ __ ] gay yeah that was the biggest
hate I ever saw in my life for a gay
yeah was the black if that's why years
ago when they said they'll put gay blaze
there be a Alpha yeah I don't know good
walk yeah gay players the NFL good luck
well they're in there they're in there
in there but they're in the closet big
because they know sure that there's a
furnace that means when Ricky Jackson
heard it was about somebody went
upstairs everything Ricky goes on both
sides of yeah right at his [ __ ] about
two days later
Ricky Williams Ricky the guy from New
Orleans yeah yeah he's got that vibe I
could see that I said that one yeah it
was a New Orleans I could see that that
was one of the rumors and then they
shipped him rundown yeah I could see
that they seemed like someone who was
just like like you're the hippie he was
a hippie a just whoever whatever so he
can actually give a [ __ ] about buddy
yeah I don't use for money he's married
now he's got a kid but people started
off as an add-on that guy Gary you don't
I guarantee ya I one night and went home
with a guy okay for a day to be is it a
shot man McGary these swamps pit with
some guy is lifted listen I got gay
friend I got a gay friend tells me we
laugh he says to me you know many guys
two beers and a shove and they'll take a
shot the other team and he says to me
and I've seen I know stories from him he
was with the Andy Warhol crew he's got
great stories about people we know now
that have experimented but that happens
a lot that happens a lot in show
business Mike
god III I'm not lament your names
obviously but my god does that happen a
lot you know hey hey how do you feel you
know like James Franco is a guy like
that a lot of guys no I don't want to go
through life with one hand one hand tied
behind my back you know I'm not run
nowadays everything's about being
gender-fluid and hey you know I'm not
gonna put down what this guy does you
know hey you know act as a great like
that but the American public the the
vast majority the movie-going public
doesn't want to know that they're not
ready for that
you can't tell a guy in Illinois James
Franco sucked a [ __ ] wants to try when I
used to come home from my my gossip
rounds I lived in the West Village other
than other than the gayest building I
was in the Meatpacking District Horatio
and Washington I mean and I had three
Yorkie so people thought that I must
have been you know playing on both sides
but I come on four o'clock in the
morning and I'd see all the
transvestites there and I went around a
couple nights with gonna I'll be sure
come on
yeah so I'll be and I would drive Albie
I loved album because he loved them and
I'll be love to fight when we go to
nightclubs that there was any [ __ ] he
would jump right off of me and we fight
guys and one night we'll drive around
his Range Rover and he goes I'll Drive
you home all right he goes watch this
and my area was all trashed and he stops
the car with a bunch of [ __ ] and he
he likes it he puts that as his uh his
dark window
and he goes uh hey baby what's going on
and this [ __ ] goes oh my god I'll be
sure what the [ __ ] oh my god now five
other trainees come and he puts the
window up and we drive off and they're
running after us he he liked that he
liked having that kind of that kind of
relationship or that kind of fun with
the [ __ ] crap and when I get home from
my rounds there was a couple of was one
girl named Coco huh who I'd see what the
[ __ ] deli downstairs putting makeup
on in the mirror right and she would
tell me Amy aging Mike Tyson was here
tonight
our city I was here tonight Eddie Murphy
came tonight there I've been there
limousine stop but I've seen the girls
I'm like you're full of [ __ ] she goes I
am and now you look back I completely
believe it Eddie Murphy
come on getting pulled over on Sunset
taking that [ __ ] home I've seen you
all can you can you sitting that right
down here and tell me unequivocally he's
straight you can't Mike Tyson I think he
likes anything Mike Tyson no no no I
love Mike I just was with him last week
I'm saying when you're that sexual I
think Mike is one of those guys that has
taken a shot with everybody I really
think that I think if we guys the rumors
I Justin was [ __ ] up on coke like he
was getting and some dude said I'll suck
your dick Mike with let your I like guys
suck I don't know anyone's [ __ ] litt
like this is that's Ryan that's a great
Allison I remember working on the best
damn sports show and I'm Darryl one of
the girls in wardrobe something was
black and we became friends
nothing I'm not nothing like that we've
just other set a fan of stand-up yeah
that one night she was explained to me
about the whole other Murphy thing as
guys I was blown the [ __ ] oh oh look at
his wife that looks like a man the COS
ex-wife Nicole my my [ __ ] film Milan
yeah no no kids 48 hours and trading
places come on no it wouldn't make a
difference to me Donna I don't get was a
clear I don't I always knew Judas Priest
singer was gay I know when I was [ __ ]
19 19 17 I knew this guy jumped the
fence had to make a difference to me
right it never did my mother didn't
raise me at all yeah I don't carry kids
I don't care I'm just intrigued by it
I wasn't even intrigued by it I just
didn't I was more blown away like when
they said Eddie Murphy and then I never
gone home that night not saying a word
and not like I don't know what the [ __ ]
Eddie Murphy I could he sold it yeah he
did I saw about the Comedy Store and
everything one away yeah yeah yeah
everything one away
Wow it was dressed who he was with I
Isis yeah and then I saw banks richer
prize old manager one
and he goes Cuba watch watch watch me
[ __ ] with these [ __ ] there was
a D Arsenio the singer from Boston oh
yeah what's the guys I don't know his
name come on the singer throw lead
singer from Bobby Brown what bad was
Bobby [ __ ] Brown a first edition
first edition yeah who's the first
edition get the five carry this is fine
I didn't think of their names I know
who's the most singer that the blacks
sing a really good-looking I can't go
cool black singer though no I don't know
what there's no edition so with this is
just a new edition just the bad new
edition Bobby Brown Johnny Gill kill yo
big time you go no doubt it was every
bird free that didn't he doesn't if
there was any Mercedes guest house
Johnny Gill Arsenio Hall man and Paul
Mooney okay they're sitting by The
Comedy Store sign and banks walks up to
me and Rogen maybe somebody else thing
goes hey watch me [ __ ] with these
[ __ ] and he goes up thing goes
hey what are you guys gonna do the
Queen's a comedy tour like right for
their faces let us say nothing to and as
soon as uh somebody Charlie Gill walked
away
Charlie myrtana Eddie Murphy like just
nickel form real he came over again if
you listen this doesn't bother me at all
yeah and I wasn't let you know this [ __ ]
we see ya and Johnny you lived in
Eddie's guest house fro come out a big
fan Eddie Murphy still love him I might
say Eddie Murphy used to come in and tip
my wife a hard stick for three waters
really that's great we guard stick say
y'all ready waitress who went on those
guys are the best I'm one that my wife
gave him two orders he came in there
with Johnny Joe and when I said I was
walking to pink that to the car and I
heard a car beat and it was Annie and
Johnnie your they pulled dog lady goes I
forgot to give you this [ __ ] guy
I love anymore yeah that's great stuff
and that's the other funny ring I hit my
wife I tell ya my wife will die it's a
funny thing about the negative responses
you've gone to that story about Marty
arm about Martin because yes you said
the word [ __ ] but it was a
positive story though and this is what
happened he did something you know I
came from a macho society yeah yeah
macho society right not to mention I
tell people I grew up in North Bergen
New Jersey
mmm this is really weird and I already
know this for sure
ah I always knew I thought a little
[ __ ] crazy I grew up in North Bergen
New Jersey when I moved there was the
Italian Irish said all right but it was
Italians that moved on up from Hoboken
yeah and then I watched the Sinatra
documentary how those Italians were not
allowed because there were tellings and
the Irish were [ __ ] with them they
weren't a lot about above ninth Street
in the forties yeah so these kids
parents that I was talking to him I was
like a Scalise for example I would go to
the house in the summer and eat and she
would say let me tell you how much he
paying for that concert what'd he do
twenty-two let me tell you why scenes
put $3 at st. Roch dry exactly I saw
said that Sinatra this guy and I had
money for Chinese have Mike let you go
listen excuse me you silly
it's you about one of those dances I'll
talk to Sinatra yeah the mother right
right everybody know everybody now till
now yeah it's all those people from
Hoboken move to North Bergen so I always
tell people I'm from North Bergen but I
got my mother died who took me in
Sicilian small mother who's the baby's
Godfather
who's they're all from Hoboken and we
all you know I got to tell people I
can't sing I got one thing from Hoboken
balls I don't give a f--- Roberts head I
came out here to swing you know yeah
like Sinatra the swing and it's just
really weird that people at how we want
people understand like you got to stick
up for yourself
mmm and these two dudes said to him one
day I mean I ain't talking they were
drinking they were both bookies one
guy's name was another and his brother
was Alberto Alberto had a regular job
but I daughter was the bookmaker that
belonged to the bar right from 10:00 to
3:00 to 10:00 to 5:00 he sat at that
stool yeah
10 to 3 took lovers at 3 the number took
off but if you wanted to give them
action for the next day he'd stay there
till 5 but they get their drink on and
one thing I did drink that Martin was
going into the city to sell coke he came
and it was because around the corner
from my mom's ma was the last bus stop
to take the New York City was in front
of a post office yeah couple other Union
City New Jersey fixed we all can make
yeah I know y'all can sure right on a
tunnel right out of the tunnel so Martin
came in and I was playing that stupid
game in that stupid game that was
bowling pins and you have a metal puck
and that have sawdust
yeah yes I was being of course I'm
playing this game yeah this is
unimaginable to you and I'm playing this
game but Martin's where you are yeah and
the bookies over he is so he says my
game that gave my digger money come and
there was like a minute of comments I
and then my team went in his back
no I pulled on like a 38 he goes oh and
let me tell you something unless I
sucked your dick or you suck my dick
then you call me Martin Tim money Cole
until then you call me Martine and my
mom's yelling at Morton to put the gun
down co calls for his right behind you
cuz she know Berto backed yeah Coco's
right behind you don't get this [ __ ] off
as a bargain you're gonna hold on
Torrio's better cuz that's my real name
Jose and Tony how are ya so host I told
you when I eat I froze I was right there
and he's like no guy I call me a [ __ ]
I get mint in there and then my mother
said come again
Martine Coco's dance she gonna he goes
Coco needs to see this is a gang anymore
my mom started yelling get the [ __ ] out
you're not allowed in here get morphine
I don't care how long I love [ __ ] he
pulled the gun I disappeared I was just
shocked they said something to each
other I never thought about again three
days later there was a knock
I opened it up it was Martin Nino's I
really apologize for taking the gun
fully my mom won't let me in the bar
unless I apologize Diego Martin are you
[ __ ] can I stray you're my personal
childhood I [ __ ] Charles for an
awesome you are the king what you did
that day in front of me that his friend
you blew every circuit in my mind now
when I was like six I saw my stepdad
beat up a guy in the Bronx for hitting
the dog you know humans all humans in
fact they said Lazarus birthday December
17th I stayed up last night a little
purple nice yeah yeah today is December
17th today's don't hit a dog dog
excursion a year from now you'll be in
[ __ ] crutches saying oh you'll have
leprosy that's all so he hit a guy for
that that's big and cute but I didn't
the dog and then when talks are along
with you and then what time is it uh and
I've Santeria party he shot a guy in the
leg Broadway and then we got in the
Clayton gun it was right Broadway goes
down into Riverside Drive yeah those
days we haven't right by there there was
a park I'll never forget we ran up 147
cuz 148 was came up to came up the hill
right 147 went down he parked on like
147th and brought away we made a right
we drove a couple blocks he was white
he'd say yeah we drove home he never
said anything again never say anything
again
so then I already seen the real deal
yeah but what he did that afternoon at
40 after little [ __ ] gray to blew me
away sighs I always loved the guy until
I robbed the blade was doing somebody's
cocaine but enough to love them I love
the businesses business yeah no don't I
[ __ ] up as a kid I [ __ ] up I know
what I never but it's funny that you
said something because I have a video on
YouTube that people really getting
pissed at me nobody is what happened I
just miss said the word foul or just say
well we were kids we used to go to
Boulevard East sick
18 17 18 we used to go to Boulevard East
and mug dudes that were coming that
would get drunk in the city
and we'll go over looking for Dyna suck
their dick Wow and on the street with
guys would stand by Boulevard East by
suicide bridge really if you want to get
your dick sucked having a while we just
started hanging out there and we'd make
guys pull over get out of the car will
suck a dick under the tree Wow will we
jump in and I said [ __ ] but I should have
said no g-man yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
no another 10 of those guys were guys
are probably married Brian just of
course they were sure sure yeah I had a
buddy who it wasn't my scene I wasn't I
didn't do coke as a kid I didn't do coke
till I did coke in college and I got out
of college my father died when I was 21
and when I got out of Cup one of my
buddies came back from college and he
had Coke and a tin foil wrapper I said
what is this yeah try it's coke I said
what year is this this is 1980 I was 21
so I was one at 62 you know 83 82 anyone
like that anyone and I said that is
still [ __ ] the way I was great I
tried it I said look my [ __ ] throat
closed up my father just died my father
was undercover narc agent so I just I
had a bad feeling about my throat closed
up naturally an hour later I loved it
and I loved it and then I didn't do coke
again I just said now I'm done I got
married young my first wife my bachelor
party of course we did coke I had in
1980s wedding so forget about it my all
my Oscars Waylon cult they [ __ ] that
bloody noses please I have the pictures
with the white church of the red thread
spots no Coke again and in like in 1990
I don't know for fun of them is 7 6 1996
my nephew is in college and he goes me
and my buddy want to try cocaine and I
said oh you're not gonna try it I'm
gonna try it no you're gonna do it with
me I don't want you going some jerk-off
and get some bear out I'll get the stuff
I have all I know who'll to get it from
and I did it with them and then I got
hooked I could I didn't like in my 20s I
could just drop in didn't care about it
but in my 30s that's what so [ __ ] up
about that drug you don't know
I couldn't couldn't get enough of it so
for a long time it was like I did it
constantly whenever I could I had plenty
of money plenty of time I wasn't I was
working like two days out of ten I'd
film a few shows and then I was off
forever so it was easy I was home and
it's so weird and then then it became a
problem for me but yeah that's a [ __ ]
way but my buddy
he got so crazy with it that he would go
try to cop some crack and this is what
he did
he tells some guys who were driving
around with cracky I want to see what
you got
and he drive what he drive with the car
and he'd say I want a cop and they'd
show him the crack in the hand and he
[ __ ] hit them with a hammer
and the crack would fully grab the crack
and he drove off so he did this like
five or six times he got a bunch of
crack the word got out you got guys with
welts on their head the size of golf
balls
there was a small hammer but [ __ ] you
know you go down so that was his big
ploy for a while that hit the guys in
the head with a hammer for Crowder play
but he said he got him at the jail got
let on fire he's dead [ __ ] guy Glen
Glen edge rich he got a little on
[ __ ] fire oh my god
evil Oh totally better buddy oh my god I
can't I can't look at it
greetings to podcast ville this episode
of the church what's happened now is
brought to you by Anka if you ever
wanted to make a podcast like this one
what thought the process will be
expensive and horrible no need to worry
anchor is the quickest and easiest way
to make and distribute your own podcasts
just don't just download the app record
with your phone and bad publish bets of
all it's completely free on the arm so
check it out and make your own podcast
at anchor dot F M slash Church that's
anchor dot F M slash Church this podcast
is also brought to you by my favorite
product in the whole [ __ ] world
- Sheba day aka hello - she calm listen
it's that timely year when you look at
your relatives you know like I wonder
what my grandmother's [ __ ] smells
like while she's making pasta or [ __ ]
lasagna you got and she's eating [ __ ]
the whole morning in front of you and
you're like I wonder what my
grandmother's [ __ ] must smell like
listen you don't have to want to know
more because we're all does she you know
it smells [ __ ] good hello [ __ ] has a
portable bidet you would store right in
your own [ __ ] back room do you
understand me no more stories no more
nothing you could defeat that hemorrhoid
juice could kill that [ __ ] those
barnacles have your wife shave you
[ __ ]
like I did and then hit it with that
[ __ ] war every day and you [ __ ]
it'll be tip-top Magoo in the width you
rub a little [ __ ] hand cream money
[ __ ] and it's [ __ ] perfect the
moon do you understand me
hello do she also makes towels and also
they come in different colors but listen
seriously I'm finally more [ __ ] years
can you give somebody a time or wallet
or something they ain't gonna do dick
you want to give something a gift cuz
you want to change their life right or
wrong give me a [ __ ] bottle birthday
and make sure their [ __ ] is tip-top
Magoo year round with a good [ __ ]
attitude go - hello - she calm and use
crutches anyone dates I got no [ __ ]
dates alright that's how we're doing it
AJ Benza still on there that is [ __ ]
hysterical yeah fine yeah his brother
was my best friend
he was in that of the joint Ronnie
Ronnie was the bet Ronnie when I hear
you I know you for years but I just
because I started my podcast six months
ago I'm into podcasts now and I started
listening to yours and you sound just
like the guys I grew up with except you
sound exactly like my buddy Ronnie
Miceli
in and out of the joint the funniest
[ __ ] guy in a world with friends
since was six years old
he's down in Florida now of course what
everybody goes when they gotta [ __ ]
run away from [ __ ] she liked him you
like a lot of guys I grew up my cousin
Phil who's a building inspector you got
all that stuff so when I hit listen to
you talk I get so into it cuz I
feel like I'm listen to my buddies it's
the best I love it now you went to
college with CW Post at Loyola to be a
writer I went for journalism yeah I come
out and I didn't want to go to [ __ ]
you know Ohio to be a reporter or
Alabama no normal you got to leave New
York to get into a newspaper job I said
I'm not leaving I can't leave I can't I
could never leave my mother and father
and I got a part-time job at Newsday
which was a big newspaper and on the
island Big Bite top [ __ ] five in the
country and I was doing high school and
college sports and that was nice I go to
games write the [ __ ] highlights I
enjoyed I like being around sports and I
wanted to be a full-time write it wasn't
happening and then eventually after like
five six years one night this is great I
got divorce got divorced I had a little
money and I sold my house and I said I'm
gonna go to [ __ ] New York was vogue
magazines hundredth birthday party at
the [ __ ] some Museum in Manhattan and
I didn't know anybody I said I'm going
I'm going
so I [ __ ] go to New York I try to get
through everybody's there velvet ropes
you name it Bob why there was no way I
was gonna get in and as I'm trying to
get in
Mickey Rourke gets thrown out and I love
Mickey Pope of Greenwich Village I still
have the tattoo and my nickname is Pope
for [ __ ] 30 years because of that
movie so he gets thrown out and it was
like yeah I couldn't make this up he
turns around looks at me and he goes
where are you going I said I don't know
I couldn't even speak too much Mickey
Rourke he goes getting a call we're
gonna go downtown just like that he
didn't know me from Adam I get in a
black town car his buddy's driving he's
got Bob Dylan on knock knock knockin on
heaven's door Mickey's gettin hard we're
goin downtown
we end up a place called wrecks downtown
he says don't worry in two hours the
whole [ __ ] party's gonna be here two
hours later Naomi Campbell Cindy
Crawford Claudia ship yeah every girl
you can imagine walks in they're all
over Mickey Mickey isn't that and I saw
a [ __ ] that night I saw Cindy Crawford
making out with chicks I saw girls put
hands down Mickey's pair insanity and
I'm a guy who was just married for five
years on Long Island footing up [ __ ]
wallpaper with my wife going to Home
Depot on the weekends I was a regular
guy and I said Jesus Christ so the next
day I called the gossip columnist at New
York Newsday and I said you know I work
at Newsday in the sports buy so that was
out last night I got a couple of tips
for you I saw I told her what happened
she goes Wow she says why don't you go
out for me every few nights I'll give
you 50 bucks a night just bring stories
backwards all right so I started hitting
Manhattan I knew nobody what years this
is 1991 I knew nobody and I'd wait there
by the velvet rope like an [ __ ] I'd
wait there and I had a little bit of
money I was doing something you number
the tout services what you caught
gamblers with hey why'd you play for
Mike Duffy I knew Mike no I was what's
to finally the still still raised me on
that I went to Stewart's in Long Island
still doing it on the internet god bless
him you go to Instagram and look it's to
funnies out of his [ __ ] money still
love him I just saw him not too long I
love the guy he said he's an animal he
taught me and I worked for major way
Jevon Kearse Oh curly slope yeah I
remember that name but I didn't work
from now I knew that I was a captain I
would recur this you did in Colorado oh
wow this is Lane d1 okay so I worked for
Curtis yeah Colorado it's too funny that
would come out and what happened was
that I worked for him for two football
seasons I was terrible uh-huh but they
had to pay me the second season because
they can peddle oh well they guys quit
that they grew up with because all those
how guys had grown up together I know I
told that story all the time we they
were Jewish the Sloat's him his brother
his mother did this is a basement by
themselves they taught me how to close
it made seven hundred thousand dollars
no no [ __ ] the first football season
ever
yeah the mother and the two sons did in
the basement the guy your guy asked all
the mothers do it and send them leads
still it's it's a massive business
how much did the guy yet his no his way
it works the way it works is you get
leads you we used to get the list of
names from casinos in Vegas or Atlantic
City of guys who gambled and then you
cold called them and you'd say how the
games treatin you whatever the [ __ ] you
use a different name and back then they
could pay you through what's the Union
through visa Madison [ __ ] card I'm
going to know exactly you're gonna sit
there better what 200 a game like a moot
that you are I'm telling you about
what's that yeah I know right yeah
that's is there a line of [ __ ] coke I
just got from the [ __ ] Colombians oh
listen to me I'm gonna go out to that
with this Chinese girl she's gonna suck
[ __ ] my balls or she doesn't know I
love it you're gonna sit your little
[ __ ] apartment in the Bronx
yeah after wishing that you would now
what are you bet is opposite mine I have
a [ __ ] card I'm gonna do it oh forget
about doing oh let's bang one in for 10
G's right now as a matter of fact put me
on hold
go in your mother's room get the [ __ ]
phone grab that phone and top all the
book and see how much you can put in it
right now I'll [ __ ] hold right now
Leila died I guarantee you you won't be
[ __ ] sorry what I'm asking for a
measly 300 you miss Herman Ferris in
myself embarrass my son I'm gonna forget
one night because the first season I did
he fired me because I was just don't
blow yeah sandwiches blow and be I was
just making so much three hours an IV
where I was I had my check was gonna
turn I was a Devorah and the other half
I had the pork in on the arm so he came
to me they listened courage from the
spoon to do the show on Friday nights
come in I want my guys to come in and we
need to come in you can make a couple
hundreds coming on Friday nights from 6
to 12 yeah and I would go then the guy
would stop by 11:00 drop the package or
well spray so he let me go in January he
goes Joey I can't ask a paper you know
are you III I wasn't doing I was there I
did a few bumps here and there but
there's a guy he's insane did really
well and I quit because of football
season ending yeah yeah yeah yeah
football was the big one and I moved to
Seattle and I bought a sports magazine I
go he did all his [ __ ] l-listen anyway
yeah you did it alone I didn't tell I
did it all to one of their friends but
the phone bill gets I know at that time
it was one 800 was for free
ah I got a deal with one 800 coming in
was for free and I would call you back
and let me tell you a really funny story
[ __ ] I did it and I called one of
Kurt's friends and as I was talking full
I knew Kurt telling me a story about
this Greek guy and he goes what do you
want doing I'm looking for my leads
I want to cold call people out of here
he goes who did you work for before I
told him and that night I'm sitting
there watching TV and when I hear the
COBOL oh yeah it's to find the
threatening me you [ __ ] next
time I say it was a fine it was the bet
so listen this [ __ ] guy I'm done with
still and a big guy named Andy Carpy
paid five hundred fifty [ __ ] pounds
you forget about it so we're making
calls and I was good at it
one day I hooked into a guy named Paul
Hicks he was a [ __ ] stockbroker in
Colorado but Loveland Colorado but he
was into all sorts of [ __ ] he was [ __ ]
betting a lot of money and out of
nowhere Stu says to me telling you going
I'm 21
telling me 22 tell me you gonna Vegas
and you're taking your five best
customers everybody's giving you $60,000
you're gonna turn it into 250,000 s I'm
like is this gonna [ __ ] work you just
do it I can pull all this I'm gonna
Vegas but by telling the whole scam I
says you can meet me out there
I'll turn the money around I'll give you
four or five times on your investment
just okay my name is Johnny Rourke I use
Johnny rueake he's Frankie Nolan Eddie
grant
he's just ok Johnny I'll be out there
sigh I'll make it right so we go we fly
into Vegas and what my buddy Mitch was a
big coke head clear the limousine I'm
waiting at the airport
it comes he'll look like Richard
Dreyfuss he's coming in his pants with
too long his heels with hitting the
[ __ ] back of his suit and he has a
briefcase in his hand he gets into the
limousine and we're going to Caesars
Palace and what talk and we get in the
room I opened the briefcase and I'm
counting the money I'm looking for 60
grand and he's talking to Mitch and I go
I said
you know Mitch is a black belt in Kung
Fu and Tai Kuan
all that [ __ ] and I just made a lot man
Paul goes all the black belt as well
what form do you use Mitch wasn't a
black belt he was a Mitch goes I don't
wanna talk about I I killed a man five
years ago it's very I can't talk about I
said Paul I'm counting the money you
sure $3,800
oh I'm sorry Johnny he's pulling money
out of his [ __ ] top shirt pocket his
[ __ ] pants his underwear okay good I
said go home relax I got it from here
naturally all he did is get coke
get girls [ __ ] gamble we lost
60 grand and two days gone oh so I got a
I call still I says a you know he's just
gone back get another 20 Isis all right
so I called Paul just hey Johnny handle
the guys's not not good oh really yes I
need 20,000 more well Johnny I said Paul
III got the game Yankees Toronto Blue
Jays I know exactly what's going on we
got an umpire on our side do me a
[ __ ] favor he's calling balls and
strikes don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ] this
isn't a gold mine this is the game get
the twenty thousand west okay Johnny
he sends it all over but at that point I
just took 220 and left I wasn't gonna
[ __ ] around so I told Stu
we lost above about I left but the point
is I had money in my pocket and we did
so well that we had a TV show that was
that was actually on sir on ESPN for a
while was called football forecast and
it was for you know four of us from
different sports agencies with a host
and we give out [ __ ] art pics we
couldn't mention the spread but we say I
think the giant sure went by at least
six tomorrow Bob Papa and people would
see the show and call it and the Falls
of [ __ ] light up the money was I got
a guy named calmo Zack who was an owner
of a half owner of the Charlotte Bobcats
back then he had irrigation systems in
the Carolinas the guy was filthy [ __ ]
rich we called him the elephant the guy
would bet 50 60 80 thousand dollars a
night and I hooked him up with John
Gotti's operation that's how the whole
mean Gotti thing happened because his
bookie
and I couldn't afford to have him with
no book he so I said I can find a guy
for you so I called my cousin Albert who
was hooked up with working for John I
said I need a guy I got a guy here he's
betting [ __ ] big O's do you vouch for
him now I didn't understand that term
vouch for him backed I said yeah the
guy's [ __ ] lowlife ouch from he says
AJ you vouch for him it's important
since Alberti I vouch for him
so we're gambling the guy's waiting and
he's losing his pain he's getting paid
and suddenly after the third week this
is the kind of guy who had like a half a
million dollars rolling on a [ __ ]
night in college basketball he'd bet
Creighton ver straight like the worst
teams you bet and long story short he
fell out he was down like $48,000 and he
had to pay I says I said listen Carl you
can't [ __ ] around this is not your
bookie in Nebraska this is a big [ __ ]
guy
I know I know Johnny I'll pay he sends
$500 which is an insult to anybody
that's running a house let alone gaudy
Thanksgiving time John Gotti calls my
house Thanksgiving throwing dinner and
says hey listen to me he goes listen to
me your friend no good he says this is
1985 now he says he's in Colorado I'm
gonna send you and Albert to Colorado
not to learn how to ski to get my
[ __ ] money you understand me I said
okay okay and he said the best line he
goes in a business with no ethics
we gotta have ethics sued he said to me
it's okay okay
he hangs up I said Albert the [ __ ]
money's a AJ get that [ __ ] money the
guy I could never find the guy again now
this is Thanksgiving if you remember
December 14th whatever it was 85 Gotti
and company wax cast Olano in front of
sparks steakhouse it becomes Godfather
and apparently everything changed in his
life he didn't care about the debt he
didn't care about that money that my guy
Odom and it went away it went away so I
no and John because of that he broke my
balls because of that John was a big
game John was a big bad gambler hadi was
the worst E he would give you he said
I'd bet against two cockroaches running
across the street I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm not you know but those so I had
money so when I went to that party I'm a
Mickey was there I was running around
throwing dollars around and long story
short Mickey we went to the party at Rex
the chick showed up I told that gossip
columnist so I started going out and
seeing [ __ ] and in time the woman who
hired me got hired by the New York Daily
News and she took me with her and she
goes how much money do you want to make
Mort Zuckerman bought the news and he's
bringing me over he wants me to
I said I want you what do you want to
make I said I don't know I had no clue I
don't know I said 6070 thousand just
done no problem
should ask for a hundred so I came in at
sixty years whatever the [ __ ] 65 and
then back in the 90s it was so different
I would get raises like every eight
months I walk in our page was so good we
were breaking such big stories that I
would walk in and she tell me go ask for
more money get more money I'd say really
just go in there and get my money and
I'm walking in say I broke this story
that story this story okay I said I
think I should make 90 now and I get I'd
make 90 it this went on for two years to
the point where I was making I was
making a you know 200 and change as a
gossip columns where all my meals paid
for my drinks before all my flights paid
for I was flying high and I made a
regular kid in the city I'm working in
Manhattan in 84 in 85 and that would go
out four nights a week and I can't sit
here cuz I was coked up and [ __ ] play
a little up I was peeled up I didn't do
coke back then but I remember certain
situations that you ever you would and I
know you you were slick dude you'll find
five dudes helping you
no you have a guy had area yeah you're
saying you have a card yeah you had a
guy at the black man clause Oh kid you
had a guy and you had a guy in Jersey
Clyde whatever
always alone always alone just to see
who would show up course and the guy
would call you know you're not gonna
believe we just went across Brad Pitt
with a blonde with a wiggle and then and
there you go I used to work as scores
was the big magnet big mecca back then I
remember one thing I still never one of
the craziest things I haven't been going
out one night seen Richard Gere no big
[ __ ] deal but the craziest not
everyone that was in 84 and I saw your
boy Mickey no oh boy I know you missed
me
I know you miss me Oh : I saw I know
boys when did your heroine out oh yeah
anything with a war and those days there
was no [ __ ] cell phone sleep yeah it
was the best memory it was no cell phone
nothing and you could walk into a club
and see three people on a table drinking
drinks forget about a mirror would cope
Yeah right there right there
I mean yeah that would not have liked to
kill guys you won't win a couple guns
they put a gun crazy get it I used to
see oh my god I would go to regular I
was never a scene in my life I was a
gender other New Jersey guy listen if I
could save a hundred bucks of snow an
extra gram ah that's what I did I'm
gonna call this city a [ __ ] ramp yeah
the babe and the tall this Sunday I go
over to the rooftop some nights I go an
area you know and then I got a job at
the Sheraton or 52nd and 7th and you're
gonna have one so you already had at one
you stole a yardstick yeah we made two
yard sticks you're in the middle of the
city a what am i that money defy my dog
that money is gone ah catch a [ __ ]
you get a cab downtown you already got a
package on you you would just walk into
a bar as [ __ ] things going on how
great was how great was that the fact
that you
I to this day when I go to New York and
I land that I'm in Manhattan especially
downtown
I remember today I had a Mercedes 500sl
I [ __ ] I was the okay I was the man
because of my job and I had a [ __ ]
super gossip he's gotta be like yeah I
didn't pay a [ __ ] doctor listen I
took Lawrence's girl I I remember taking
Randal Cunningham's wife to China Club
and [ __ ] Lauren's tailor going you
the [ __ ] man [ __ ] cuz this is like
you know when Randall Cunningham was the
man and Lawrence Taylor was I was dating
downtown Julie brown when Lawrence
Taylor was kind of dating or wanting to
get in there oh it was that the scene
back then was the Palladium but it was
the lady and limelight there was so many
places to go and be seen so I was
plugged into all of it all of it and
everybody would call me and when you're
a gossip columnist there a publicist and
they're all [ __ ] cute they were all
hot they all wore black clothes and they
all they all want their clients in the
paper and they all want their they
represent a shoe store on West Broadway
they went and I would just sit there I
mean I would go to spy bar which was on
Green Street which was the hottest
[ __ ] spot in the 90s and I had a
buyer I might had a buddy named Johnny
boy calvini who is 67 maybe big pothead
and we wrote he had an old Mercedes out
of no.1 we drive around and they would
move the [ __ ] cones we talk in front
of the club which is that those little
things like that means so much when you
can just roll up to the club and they
just let you talk in front of the club
and you toss the keys to the guy and he
would say I don't care what you do the
rest of your life when you get older you
better remember they [ __ ] move the
cones for us on West Broadway and you
said earlier you he was leave us doing a
bond here you said this is the [ __ ] that
killed Castro Johnny would say this is
the [ __ ] that killed Bruce Lee that was
his line and Johnny would say we'd sit
at the piano at spy bar which is
about five feet above the crowd and John
even said to me you know what he goes if
you were up in space and you looked down
on earth and you look down on America
and in America you go down in New York
City and in New York City you look down
in Greenwich Village and in Greenwich
Village you when Spring Street and
Spring Street you found spy barn and spy
bar you found the [ __ ] piano you'd
find us body he'd say what a [ __ ]
kings of the world and back then as
stupid as it sounds that was true to be
at the piano at spy bar and the 90s with
everybody running around [ __ ] insane
we were kings kings of the city well
after that talk we just had what are the
people around do you think when you said
you were gonna gossip columnist they
it's a very powerful position and you
have people around town and the reason
why my podcast kind of took off the last
few the last seven eight weeks is
because I was a really good friend and I
still AM of Harvey Weinstein's and I am
I love the guy I love the guy and I talk
to him all the time I talk to him all
the time and he was mad at me that I was
in the New York Times article and is a
picture of me and but the point is it
was all that free Harvey all right no
I'm just saying I love Harvey he did
some bad [ __ ] and we'll see what he's
guilty of however that [ __ ] put
out the best [ __ ] movies you could
think of and I know that things sound
awful and I don't want to disagree with
the girls who said would happen to
happen I don't think I don't think a lot
of girls lie but I will say this for
every girl who got molested or raped I
think there are five others who went up
to that [ __ ] hotel room and let him
wear the robe
and let him jerk off that's Hollywood
but I'm not taking away from the girls
who God don't I'm not because I believe
them I just loved it I wasn't gonna
bring love yeah cause I got a friend
listening - Harvey I talked to Matt so
Matt he got so mad at me okay
I'm sorry going no remember that episode
pull only what and just put on YouTube
okay
the honeymoon is Harvey oh the Harvey
honeymooners episode I'm gonna Harvey
sad obviously girlfriend go ahead my
friends love he's even bigger than me
remember that guy I got a friend Shirley
who's bigger than you how does their
lying [ __ ] here that was great before
I came here I left to see what episode
was on for that all Atlanta classic
tonight an 11 o'clock on channel 12 out
of 20 right I know tonight's the one way
throws his wife out he makes a record
all emotional but he has to make the
third record final easily there's a
sweet one but Norton descends in the
wrong record the one that he's really
angry and he calls his wife a big mouth
at aha it's a classic episode I got on
tape so I don't give a Frenchman's [ __ ]
it's it's that's the moon way Ted Jesus
yeah they got it the Baba
Roth me toffee Harvey was a great actor
this [ __ ] was big this oh [ __ ]
here we go right there's but its own
here we go my heart and javi said
[Music]
can you print our B or B you can tell
huh and then I say well I got a nice
name my name Harvey I don't tell ha me
go ahead and tell him
stumpy mighty scared I'm shaking the
duck you better be careful my friend is
even bigger than me your friend Harvey
is bigger than you
I have a friend Shirley this big mill
keep watching I really very lucky do
watch this for watch our hobby talks
watch shall we - hi Tori you're not
gonna get the table well go away and you
Peter kill Bobby
hey-ya Ralphie's even bigger than your
friend Cheryl huh those bookends are
gonna be a little lopsided what are you
talking about bookends daddy was gonna
twist me and you in the book it oh yeah
so you're gonna twist me and him in the
book and that party's gonna push you and
him in a book and you got nothing to
worry about you're on the right nobody
can put you around he made fun of your
name he said Harvey was a funny name
Oh II did an obvious lovely name Oh
hobbies a funny name you're a real wise
guy huh how there's four had to be so
straight know what I might do to you
I might punch you right in the mouth no
way can't talk about that way okay pad
it is put you into a pretzel Hayden
you're gonna twist me into a pretzel I
don't even like breakfast I'll give you
a chance come on step outside the box
and twist me into a pretzel [ __ ] this
was a glance a nurse that's my
hometown's
and at the end they set him up yeah he
comes in he didn't they make a guy
bigger than him show up and he knocks
him out and the guy says even my friend
didn't show up please didn't make it
tonight Gleason and that was all one
takeaway real that was live that shallow
show that's right that's a live shot
shot wide Fox out of that line let's
shop [ __ ] lives all my life I left
throw up last night it's funny because
we know we both of the same ager for a
while when little few meetings we're
gonna do a shelf for a man and then we
both disappeared we will find them and
then you see you around and you know
this town is people go home and stuff
like that whatever yeah and that was
really really happy to see your Rocky
6.now ball render folk thank you you did
a great job and then like you know when
you don't see somebody and then you see
him [ __ ] ten times and - right right
right and a few weeks later it was some
maybe they do something else Wednesday
nights I'm one of those channels and
that was you walking six eight feet from
John Gotti
about the interview oh yeah yeah yeah
hey old tape yeah yeah and it was you
interviewed him at one point and then
the other interview was Irish guy Sean
Miller was there Noah yeah
yeah I got to be real close to him I got
to be closer to because when I worked at
Newsday I got close with John and you
know he knew me from the whole [ __ ]
gambling thing and I remember I went to
see him downtown when he was on trial I
went to the trial and that was a trip
Anthony Quinn month of the trial Mickey
Rourke went through the trial a lot of a
lot of a lot of actors go through the
trials and I remember there was one
moment where his life hung in the
balance it was gonna be gonna go to jail
forever or whatever and across from the
court downtown in Manhattan there's a
restaurant on Mott Street called Jim
bones I think it's still there it's
great [ __ ] joint real [ __ ]
old-school phone booth in a restaurant I
forget it like and I followed into the
restaurant and I sat down with them
jerry Shaw Gail Bruce Cutler Sammy the
bull but at one point Sammy the bull
he was looking me up and down and he
said to John what the [ __ ] this guy
don't was this kid and John said he's
alright and Sammy said yeah but he's
with the press he said yeah but he's
more he's more right than them I love
that saying so let me sit down and he
was good to me he was good to me and his
daughters been good to me she came to my
book party I don't know it's what you
know there are things in life that
happened that you kind of get kissed by
an angel like Y through through still
finer and the gambling thing I would
meet John Gotti and he would end up
liking me and that would end up honestly
making people think something about me
the AJ's you know AJ's around the mob
that guy and it worked and then when I
got into the night mid-90s and I started
running around
I was a nightclub called Rouge and the
Upper East Side which was all Genovese
and scores the strip club was Genovese
and Gambino and but yet mine even though
is a gossip columnist my name day under
they knew it they accepted it and they
didn't [ __ ] around with me not Agumon
Johnny get in trouble oh you know
Googlebot Johnny he was around the
doorman yeah us crew they were shaking
down the girls yeah yeah my roommate
Chico was was involved in all that and
between me and your Goomba Johnny
he was working on [ __ ] borrowed time
there's nothing he did that and made him
[ __ ] strong or tough or important a
lazy name too it's an expression of
respect to my job a strip club shaking
those other girls they all did the
strippers the strippers they [ __ ]
paid out up front they used to pay out
to everybody they get stripped everybody
shook people down it was it was I was at
a pyramid everybody got sucked down
money down to the security guards to the
[ __ ] valet guy everybody got shook
down everybody and when the mobsters
walked in Joe Watts Joe the German all
these mobsters Angelo Bruno all these
mobsters would walk in and they'd say
and you mentioned this earlier about
people paying people's rent like you
know Eddie Murphy when mafioso come to
New York City clubs
they'd approach the head of security who
was my roommate Chico who's no longer
what he died but they say cheek how many
guys are working tonight on security and
she could say yeah you know six oh yeah
and they [ __ ] [ __ ] just peel off
[ __ ] hundreds in the air take care of
the guy his [ __ ] face $2,800 take
care everybody and Chico with Duke if
you get three you get full you get two
you get five them and every my
ex-girlfriend was a bartender and I'd
see the bartenders all the girls were
hot Porter I'd see their faces when the
Mafia's would walk in they knew rent is
covered this month if Joe watts
and and Vinnie gorgeous walked in Angelo
Brewer you name it they knew okay we'll
go if a bar tend to walk the scotch and
soda to jail why's she got 250 you know
if he came in twice that week she got a
500 that week
those guys they kept the city running
they kept it old you know more than
celebrities they were just they [ __ ]
took care everybody they were great they
were great and and because i vouched for
chico i ended up being on the bad side
of them because chica at one point
started collecting money for my buddy
who was a pot dealer who he had
outstanding debts and chico said oh I'll
get you I'll get you money because one
of the big Genovese see guys Ralphie
Coppola who's now dead he liked us and
he said listen you're around me now it
was like Donnie Brasco you're around me
don't worry I don't know no one could
touch you anybody bothers you Sam with
Ralphie okay when you hear that you
think you won that you did in essence
you won the [ __ ] lottery you could do
whatever the [ __ ] you want someone
bothers you
whoa you got to talk to Ralphie and it
works so Chico was asking for money from
an old guy who's had a [ __ ] pot debt
he don't want pay he goes listen I'm a
Ralphie unfortunately that guy's father
grew up with Ralphie and he told his
father and the father call Ralphie and
said why is just kid using your name for
a [ __ ] marijuana debt so one night
Ralphie calls and says why don't you and
Chico come up to Gino's on Third Avenue
I have a [ __ ] great meal we're out
all night we're gonna drink some [ __ ]
drop buzz he me great all right we all
go to Geno's it's [ __ ] fat snowing in
Manhattan [ __ ] great best meal he
says AG once you go do your thing me and
chief we're gonna hang okay so about an
hour later I got a phone call and
Chico's just destroyed in the street
they beat the [ __ ] out of them well when
I left they walked him out that a nice
meal cigars grappa and they just punched
the [ __ ] out of him they had faith I
mean he had to have a screen put in his
stomach because his intestines were
coming out
so they beat the [ __ ] out of them and I
vouch for Chico there's that word again
vouched so I call one of my guys as an
old-time mobster I said what do I do now
I vouch for Chico I gotta go back to the
club
he said don't change anything you do go
to the club go to the ball
order your espresso with sambuca and I
did and when I went there the same guys
who would see me and hug being go crazy
aja what's going on I walked in the
[ __ ] stairs they gave me they didn't
say nothing they looked at me with
[ __ ] eyes like daggers and i sat
there at the bar and I drank my espresso
and I left and I was ready to get jumped
on Park Avenue I knew I was gonna get
jumped killed knife whatever nothing
happened
those days are awful as much fun as you
have with the guys you know wiping out a
bar in Westchester County taking
cleaning out their liquor whatever the
[ __ ] grabbing girls when you're on their
bad side oh my god is that the [ __ ]
scariest thing in the world
horrifying anyhow the guys who were
after were all dead they're all dead I
mean this is 20 years later days it's a
it's a horrible lifestyle but they're
all done when I lived in Boston I lived
in the in the North End for a couple
years
Montana stuff and yeah and the rumor was
that there were a couple people on my
street there were actually connected and
I didn't know of how much of it was true
is there actually people there North it
you know what North End yeah yeah yeah
boss tomorrow
how about Whitey Bulger for one Oh
everyone's here yeah I know yes yeah are
you know trying to get your Bello and
your podcast I I you know that'd be
great I don't know how much he's talking
yeah I would love to I try sure I don't
know how much she wants to how much he
wants to talk about it but you know
Sammy ratted I don't you know people rat
III can't even it ain't the old days and
this is what going back 20 years when he
ratted it was really not what people did
not what tough guys did but who's the
joke on everybody's dead Sammy went to
Arizona he did his time by the way he
had an ecstasy ring that was bringing in
750 thousand [ __ ] dollars a month
well he was in Arizona that's how he got
pinched he did his time he's out now
he'll probably get a foot not probably I
know he's gonna get a reality show I
know for a fact who's gonna [ __ ] be
the shell Ron I made a joke going around
on my podcast it's gonna run the couple
here in about six seven days said you
know suddenly this guy's gonna get more
work than me show me a ball taking the
heart of him for more shows than me
he'll probably be hosting a show that I
would have hosted but now Sammy the
Bulls gonna get it that's the way
Hollywood is what am I gonna do yeah you
know everybody rats I didn't the old
days you know the new guys they do guys
rat the new guys want their screenplays
to be made into movies it's a very
different mafia it's very different
don't you think you had a very
interesting life man journalist covering
all type of [ __ ] like I said one time I
watched one of your shows when you were
at the magician's house oh yeah not
Houdini somebody that was [ __ ] crazy
I'm Laurel Canyon
well David blames her buddy but it
wasn't his houses or somebody who was
dead now we had some money yeah well
that's when A&E was kickin I liked Amy a
lot that no I was on e you he you know
you he was he was hot dog but he was
nice he was a true Hollywood stories
mysteries and scammers Howard Stern he
was he was oh it was a Howard Stern was
on me that's right
holy [ __ ] I'd fires the thighs to follow
I was on after Howard I was on before
Howard and then I had a talk show after
Howard was only out for four weeks it
was a [ __ ] I'm it would have been good
but they pulled the plug cuz they were
[ __ ] nervous but those that he was
great he was he was on he was great back
then let me do what I wanted to do they
said what else do you want to do I said
I'm on a talk show okay
I grabbed the [ __ ] loft
Manhattan I I found a place downtown
with a Chinese doorman with an elevator
that went upstairs I booked the guest i
booked dan Rather al Sharpton [ __ ]
supermodels it was great but it lasted
only four weeks in the last week check
this out this is Hollywood George
Hamilton came on I said if you let me
have this show trust me people are going
to show up because it's gonna be a spot
to go before you go out my barmaids
Oprah's hot Brasilians I had alcohol in
the audience no one had alcohol yet this
is before Jimmy Kimmel no one had called
that it was the [ __ ] crowd was great
I had music acts everybody smoke weed
like it was a loft so people smoke weed
before they came on very loosey-goosey
and for the fifth show I'm ready I'm at
that I'm staying in the hotel mapo aside
I'm about to go downtown to shoot and
the girl I was dating was my little
assistant and she gets a phone call
oh okay really I'll put him on Oh what's
up I had a book my book came out was in
the window of bookstores I had a [ __ ]
TV show at a talk show and I hear listen
we're not gonna the show is not gonna go
tonight so what I mean hey Chris Rock
was a guest I had like five great guests
they they pull the plug as I'm going
down to hope to do the show lot in that
live but tape but I was going down so
they let the stars fly in and they pull
the plug and I was out of my [ __ ] mind
that's the kind of [ __ ] that happens in
Hollywood I was literally dressed and
ready to go on and they pull the [ __ ]
plug it's the worst and and Joey it took
me eight [ __ ] years there was a
lesbian boss at Ian's a Mindy Herman who
[ __ ] loved me and every article on
the reporter and variety was AJ's the
best and she pulled the plug and it
killed me for eight years and one night
I got a [ __ ] Facebook message
from Mindy Herman I go what the [ __ ] is
this I take myself I accept she does not
want to apologize it's not you it was me
I'm nervous about talk shows you were
great I'm so sorry I said do you know
what that my life has been like for the
last eight years how [ __ ] miserable
I've been now you know like that would
have been my ticket I was going back to
New York to host a talk show which is
something I always wanted to do and this
[ __ ] just decided yeah I don't wanna do
it kill me
it destroyed me but eight years I was
miserable for eight [ __ ] years that's
the business bro I'm happy you got over
there jib yeah well right now and there
you go [ __ ] Joey Coco close by
children yeah you look good
Wow that's the most important thing you
listen to it it's like [ __ ] Mick
Jagger said you can't get what you want
and I always get my job but you get what
you then we put a lot of the five things
write me a podcast are the same is a
[ __ ] when the wonders have come down
every every every Wednesday and Friday
and new episodes and you'll like it
because lately I've been the last six
seven weeks I've been outing every
pervert every [ __ ] pedophile in
Hollywood I'm very close to the Harvey
Weinstein situation so I got the goods
on every not in trouble for what for
real is there I think in trouble I
Harvey gave me a book deal 20 years ago
hobbies been my man and Harvey asked me
for help a year ago in December he text
he called me and said come to the
peninsula I need your help this is way
before anything came out I went to the
peninsula I said what's up you should
look they're doing a bad article on me
New York Magazine's gonna kill me
it's okay what do you want to do is just
why don't you write let's make-believe
let's why don't you be an author and
you're gonna write a bad book about me
I'll give you people to call and if you
call them and they tell you bad [ __ ]
about me I'll know where the bad stories
are coming from it's okay he said I'll
give you 20,000 a month's this is gonna
be fine I'm sorry
so week goes by he didn't call two weeks
no course it boss
sup you should hang tight and I never
heard back
but between me and you I said I can't
write a bad book about havi people
Norma's friend they know he doesn't work
but thank God because he didn't say the
stories of surrounding him were about
rape and chicks get molested he just
said there's a bad article coming out
and I'm the guy 13 years ago who
protected him when he was cheating on
his wife and having an affair and I
buried that story for for months and
months and months because he needed the
help because Disney and Miramax was
doing a big business endeavor so I'm
close to him but I never knew I know I
never knew this side of him never I
figured a guy like him he's a movie
mogul they get laid
starlets come to them they [ __ ] them I
understand how would use Darryl zanuck
you name the mogul you know come on it's
Hollywood but I never in a million years
ever thought [ __ ] pushing in doors
raping chair I mean no never
so him and I talked a couple of weeks
ago and he said you talked to the New
York Times I said yeah he says why would
you do that this is because the story
they came to me and was wrong they had
it wrong they had it that I suggest that
I write a book about you and I said
that's not true it's just [ __ ] I
said no hobby
that's not gonna wife and family I got a
[ __ ] career I'm not that I can't I
can't go down like that it was wrong so
I cooperated and I told the kid what was
right he says AJ you and I we're guys
that don't talk I said I understand but
it was it was full of errors and I had
to correct that he's okay what else did
you say so I told him I said and I said
not for nothing Harvey so why are you
worried about me do you know what people
are saying about you you just know I
don't tell me that's you don't know this
ain't you the call you the biggest
[ __ ] monster in the last hundred
is he said AJ everything you hear was
consensual and we went down girl by girl
I'm not gonna bore you with the details
but at the end of the phone call he said
listen you heard Clooney you're her
Damon you're these guys talk about me
Affleck
he said if I if I told everybody what I
know about this town it would fall to
its [ __ ] knees and stop I said I'm
sure you're right bro he said okay amigo
I'll see you I'll see you down the road
I said Harvey I got two pictures on my
wall in my office you and John Gotti
he said that's some [ __ ] company you
keep
I said yeah so I'm not betting against
them I'm sure he's guilty but I'm not
betting against them coming back I won't
III just think that a guy like him if he
had this script of Pulp Fiction if he
had the script to the next Pulp Fiction
now I'm telling you right now
there'd be a line up and down the 405
with people who want the accolades the
money and the fame to work with them
even what the [ __ ] fire is raging on
each side of the highway that's why this
[ __ ] town lose here brother what's
that Saint Lucia part to help kidding
what how kidding the beginning Exorcist
the archaeologists they see every finds
a little devil yeah there's a saintly
who's here in Hollywood and the other
point he's like a snowbird great to have
you on my brother I'm happy I love you
buddy about you too
those are some great [ __ ] stories
Thank You pally god bless you man
we how you don't brother I'm doing
really tonight there's only four it's
Hanukkah maybe it's another bar the rest
okay that's resting no no
there's great stories to them double
bond can I can tell by your eyes you
shot oh no about the thousand milligrams
of THC weed I didn't know about that
yeah what about that enema you gave them
earlier solely you downloaded the Hank
app I did that was a great little bit
okay it's a very cool app it's it's you
put it on what you're interested in and
what you want to hear like the latest
news stories sports I'm sure they have
stuff about gossip let's just take a
drink of water so ones you got to do but
the view is amazing people who are doing
like short 5 minute long podcasts that
they upload straight from their phone
and it's great you can call into these
separate different channels and talk to
rightly to the people who are doing the
shows it's really interesting and
there's so much content I had a really
good time looking at this afternoon well
this episode of the church is brought to
you by Anka if you ever wanted to make a
podcast like this one but thought the
process would be expensive and horrible
listen no need to worry
anchor it's the quickest and easiest way
to make downloads distribute your own
podcast period just upload yeah
record your phone record with your phone
and publish best of all it's completely
free check it out and make sure your own
podcast at anchor dot F M slash Church
that's anchored dot F M slash Church
listen for month she was sitting there
thinking about doing that podcast yet
home go I do I start a podcast how do I
start a podcast how do I start a podcast
this is your opportunity right here
download the app it's that easy alright
you want to make a podcast like this one
and I know this is scary to everybody
you think there's going to be a bunch of
computers and why isn't what boom just
download the app record with your phone
and publish the thing it's that easy
and best of all like I said before it's
completely free so check it out and make
your own podcast you ready and
dot offend again anchored dot F M /
Church that's anchor dot F M / Church
now like I said before it's the
important time of the year I know you're
writing a letter to Santa Claus and your
tongue will be still owes your money and
but the second thing on the list is that
you wanna clean [ __ ] bunchy you got
access pinecones having from your boughs
of holly and some fudge you pudding
smell a mud your muffler you don't need
this it's the holidays you want to start
2018 when they clean [ __ ] you know
what you need you need a tissue birthday
it'll clean your ass better than any
toilet paper in the [ __ ] market it
uses clean water to spray your butt
[ __ ] minty fresh without the [ __ ]
Irish Spring you following the same team
and it's portable you put it right on
your [ __ ] bathroom and there you are
I'm one of those guys I wash my ass
gonna take a shower and I'm saying the
double check that work no more skid
marks no more sugar burns fairies
hanging your body you're gonna wipe your
ass this old toilet paper there oh the
night before and it's rolled up like a
[ __ ] skinny joint like a [ __ ]
joint with no weed I'm gonna step off
yeah they're [ __ ] disgusting so
listen they all start at $69 and then
come in beautiful different colors and
I'm sure Santa can afford one of those
so stop wiping that [ __ ] nasty
[ __ ] muffler and start living like a
doctor with Russia and they come in
different colors
yes that's hello - she Tom use code
Church CH you are CH for 10% off your
order listen to me
why give that uncle the same [ __ ]
boring gift when you give that
[ __ ] up a day and know he's
gonna pay listen you give a 64 year on
to a bad day who his wife died better
than you he's gonna sit there all day
whacking that [ __ ] dick like Harvey
use a hot water pop job oh [ __ ] hello
[ __ ] calm use code Church for 10% off
your de again I want you to go with
anchor dot F M / Church that's anchor
doc F M that / Church and pushy also a
shout-out to Fuji sports.com you're
gonna make commitment you're gonna join
you jitter you want a bigger [ __ ] g
a5 a6 go to fuging at the submarine oh
you're not gonna [ __ ] tonight you
know I gotta [ __ ] be sorry
press [ __ ] Church and get 15% off you
know how we do it today
Thank You AJ Ben thank you brother I
love my bubble on Christ oh come on Lisa
at let's kill him with some [ __ ]
musically he'll take me out [ __ ]
come on take a bow